if i could do anything in my life if god  says terry i'm gonna start you over what  would you do  this is what i do  how you doing it's a story about my nfl  career and life when i was born in 1948  god made me a football player and he  gave me a strong arm i like to throw  that sucker deep here select barry  bradshaw quarterback louisiana tech here  is bradshaw touchdown  winning the championship was the key the  pittsburgh steelers are the champions of  the national football league for the  fourth time  as much as we accomplished it was hard  to enjoy  before i reached the end zone  before my final goal  as you can imagine god knows i've had a  lot of therapy  [Applause]  it's just been an amazing life  it has truly been an amazing life  oh yeah  you